Trascrizione: CHAIMAE THAILIL
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Chi di voi, da piccolo
sognava di essere un calciatore?
Chi un'astronauta?
Chi invece una rockstar?
Qualcuna di voi sognava
di essere una principessa,
o un cavaliere medievale, proprio come me?
Una delle domande più gettonate,
durante la nostra crescita,
è proprio questa:
cosa vuoi fare da grande?
E noi, da bambini, sognamo.
Però, non è facile rispondere
a questa domanda:
né se andiamo alle elementari,
né se abbiamo, magari, già 20 o 30 anni.
Pensate che qualcuno arriva
alla fine della sua vita,
e ancora non lo sa!
E sapete perché è così difficile?
Perché non è questo il punto.
Ci ho messo un po' a scoprirlo,
ma ho capito che non è questa
la domanda giusta.
Quando ero piccolo,
ero davvero un gran casinista:
non riuscivo a stare
fermo un secondo,
mi distraevo in continuazione
e in qualsiasi modo,
facevo impazzire tutti i miei insegnanti.
E credo che molti si ricordino
di me ancora oggi.
Penso di essere il loro incubo.
Ovviamente, è inutile nascondervi
che avevo dei voti davvero pessimi:
pensate che, per arrivare al sei,
dovevo riuscire a sommare
lo scritto con l'orale.
Tutti i professori,
e i miei compagni di classe,
pensavano che con me era tutto inutile,
e che non avrei mai combinato
nulla di buono nella mia vita.
Avevo una sola voce
fuori dal coro che parlava:
ed era quella di mia mamma,
che mi diceva di non mollare
e che un giorno anche io
avrei conquistato le mie stelle.
E allora, guardavo
i miei compagni di classe
e sentivo che tra noi
qualcosa era diverso.
Io mi sentivo diverso.
Il punto è che quando ti senti diverso,
la società, le persone in generale,
ti fanno sentire anche sbagliato,
come se le due parole,
"diverso" e "sbagliato",
fossero due sinonimi.
Puoi essere diverso per tanti motivi:
perché non pensi come tutti,
perché non agisci come tutti,
perché non sei come tutti.
Ed io ero esattamente così:
ero l'opposto rispetto a tutti.
Per anni non capivo.
Non capivo perché dovevo essere io
quello diverso, quello "fuori".
Poi ho capito come andavano le cose.
Ho capito che le persone
erano assalite, e comandate,
da una specie di morbo,
quello della mediocrità.
Ora vi racconto come funziona.
Tecnicamente, nasciamo
e veniamo programmati per la mediocrità.
La scuola ci insegna
che per essere promossi
basta arrivare ad un mediocre sei:
quando andiamo male in una materia,
ed eccelliamo in un'altra,
che cosa succede?
Che ci mandano a ripetizione
per arrivare a quel benedetto sei;
ma nessuno ci da un maestro
per allenare, invece,
la nostra eccellenza.
Io questo non l'ho mai capito.
Secondo voi, perché non si può
diventare ancora più bravi
in qualcosa in cui si eccelle già?
Perché nessuno ci allena
a diventare dei fuoriclasse?
Un ultimo perché:
perché per tanti è strano, e sbagliato,
scegliere di eccellere
in una cosa soltanto
e impegnarsi a farla
per il resto della vita?
E come si raggiunge
l'eccellenza, se non così?
Io, da piccolo, volevo diventare qualcuno:
volevo raggiungere sempre
un nuovo livello.
un po' come quando giocavo
a qualche videogioco
e continuavo a raggiungere
il livello successivo.
E poi, volevo fare il cavaliere.
E ho deciso di seguire
questo mio sogno fino in fondo,
vivendo anche secondo
i principi, del Cavaliere.
E oggi faccio, anche,
giostre medievali a cavallo,
proprio come si facevano nel Medioevo.
Ho deciso di non abbandonare
quel sogno che avevo da bambino.
Poi, però, ho dovuto fare
anche qualcosa di più moderno
perché con i miei servigi da cavaliere
non sarei arrivato a fine mese,
così ho deciso che sarei
diventato un imprenditore.
Ora gestisco quattro aziende,
la più grande delle quali
ha oltre 100 dipendenti.
Visto cosa ho fatto?
Ho preso una decisione, e sono diventato
un cavaliere medievale;
poi ho preso un'altra decisione,
e sono diventato
un imprenditore di successo.
È una questione di decisioni.
Secondo voi,
se avessi deciso di dare ascolto
a tutte quelle persone
che pensavano che da grande
non avrei combinato nulla,
dove sarei ora?
Interpretare questo ruolo
da cavaliere medievale
mi ha insegnato che,
se continuiamo a fare
quello che abbiamo sempre fatto,
continueremo ad ottenere
quello che abbiamo sempre ottenuto.
Ti meriti di più dalla vita,
ma non otterrai mai nulla
se non sei disposto
a rimboccarti le maniche
e a lavorare in maniera diversa.
Sapete come finisce la storia
della volpe e dell'uva?
Che dopo vari tentativi
in cui la volpe prova invano
a prendere quel grappolo,
se ne va dicendo che l'uva è acerba.
Proprio come tutte le persone
che non riescono
a raggiungere, a prendere,
a ottenere ciò che desiderano.
Cosa fanno?
Criticano, sminuiscono, distruggono
quella determinata cosa.
Iniziano a trovare scuse:
"Non si può fare, è sbagliato,
non va bene, tu non puoi".
"È acerba!"
Sono queste le parole che usano
per indurti a pensarla proprio come loro.
E qui, hai due strade:
o li ascolti, o fai di testa tua.
Vi rifaccio la domanda di prima:
Secondo voi, dove potrei essere ora io,
se avessi deciso di dare ascolto
a tutte quelle persone
che ogni giorno cercavano di sminuirmi?
Che dicevano che non avrei mai combinato
nulla di buono nella vita?
Di certo, non sarei qui con voi.
Non li dovete mai,
mai e poi mai ascoltare
quando vi dicono che qualcosa
non si può fare.
Voi fatela, e poi tornate
da quelli che hanno parlato
e dimostrate che invece voi l'avete fatta.
Questa è la differenza
fra i molti e i pochi.
I pochi hanno sempre
quella fame di crescere,
sono ossessionati dal raggiungere
il loro ivello successivo.
I pochi sono quelli che vengono ricordati
anche a distanza di millenni,
perché hanno fatto quello che molti
ritenevano impossibile.
Non sono dei supereroi:
hanno solo lavorato
sulla loro mentalità da next level.
È fondamentale, in tutto questo,
credere in noi stessi.
Certo, non si può sapere
dove andremo, chi saremo,
in cosa riusciremo e in cosa falliremo;
ma tutto questo fa parte della vita.
E abbiamo una precisa responsabilità
nei nostri stessi confronti:
quello di cercare la nostra felicità,
e lottare ogni giorno  per ottenerla.
Se date ascolto a chi non crede in voi,
finirete per dare ragione
a quelle voci, a quelle persone,
e quello che dicono si verificherà.
È difficile, lo so:
ma dentro di voi, in mezzo al buio,
c'è una luce, piccola o grande che sia,
e voi avete il dovere di alimentarla.
A volte è piccola, a volte è grande;
il vostro dovere è quello
di tenerla sempre accesa.
Sono la mente e il cuore
che ci fanno muovere
verso il prossimo livello.
Per ogni Next Level della tua vita
devi raggiungere un Next Level di te,
un Next Level per il tuo mindset,
un Next Level per la tua volontà,
un Next Level per la tenacia,
un Next Level per esprimere
ogni tuo potenziale.
Sei tu, che determini chi sei;
e se ti lasci troppo
convincere dagli altri
su qual è la tua identità,
finisci per credere di essere un pollo
quando invece sei un'aquila.
La conosci questa storia?
C'era una volta una bellissima aquila
che viveva in un pollaio
insieme a delle galline.
Un giorno questa aquila,
che si credeva una gallina,
mentre era intenta a razzolare
con le altre galline,
guardò in alto, e cosa vide?
Vide un essere piumato
e maestoso, molto simile a lei,
che volteggiava in alto nel cielo.
"Chi è? " chiese subito l'aquila
a una delle galline.
"Ah, quella è un'aquila",
disse la gallina.
"Lei, a differenza nostra,
vola in alto lassù nel cielo".
Che bello sarebbe essere come lei,
anche se so che non sarà
possibile per me".
E così, l'aquila andò a dormire
e non se ne curò più.
Pochi giorni dopo,
la maestosa aquila
che volteggiava nel cielo
notò l'aquila nel pollaio.
Planò, e le disse:
"Cara sorella, cosa ci fai qui a terra?
Vieni a volare in alto
nel cielo, insieme a me!"
E l'aquila, che si credeva
una gallina, rispose:
"Ma che dici, noi galline
non possiamo volare in alto come te!"
"Ma che dici tu!" le rispose
l'aquila maestosa,
"Guardami, e poi specchiati
in questa pozzanghera:
sei uguale a me!
Apri le tue ali,
e guarda quanto sono grandi!"
E così, questa favola ci insegna
che se ascoltiamo
ciò che ci dicono gli altri
finiremo veramente per crederci
così profondamente
da ricondurlo alla nostra identità,
vivendo una vita a metà
o con la retromarcia,
o comunque ottenendo molto meno
da quelle che sono
le nostre innate capacità.
Restiamo nel pollaio.
Quindi quando pensi ai tuoi sogni,
quando parti per realizzarli,
devi essere come un cavaliere medievale:
abbassa la visiera del tuo elmo,
e procedi dritto al galoppo
verso le tue paure,
colpendo con la lancia
il demone che è in te.
Cavalca verso i tuoi obiettivi,
e quello che vuoi essere.
Perché questa vita è breve,
e i rimpianti non ti portano
al tuo livello successivo.
Rispetto chi vuole una vita semplice,
ma fin da piccolo ho sempre pensato
che avrei voluto vivere
una vita straordinaria, fantastica.
Quella vita che molti pensano
sia impossibile da vivere.
Siete disposti a fare di tutto,
per cambiare la vostra vita?
Soprattutto, siete disposti
a credere di essere speciali,
e a impegnarvi per raggiungere
quel livello successivo?
Ecco la domanda giusta!
Non "Cosa volete fare da grandi?" ma:
"Volete, giorno dopo giorno,
andare al vostro Next Level?"
E allora, fatelo!